i know from the thumbnail it can be an
obvious fix to just say make your own
greyjoy more like his book counterpart
but i want to go in depth with what is
wrong with the show version of euron so
we can then fix his issues where did
david and dan and the actor portraying
him go so wrong
firstly to me one of the most jarring
reasons why euron sticks out in a bad
way is his acting
in the book a fire cannot kill a dragon
which is mostly a collection of
interviews behind the scenes in game of
thrones we find out a key lesson that
jason momoa and rory mccann learned
during their portrayal of khal drogo and
sandor clegane their main revelation is
that less is more and that style of
acting can speak volumes when their
physical stature alone intimidates
people they didn't have to play up their
acting and go crazy because just beaming
someone in the eyes is just as scary as
acting like a lunatic that and by going
full blown wacky in a show that
establishes a different tone and style
and acting the character euron greyjoy
stands out like a sore thumb he seems
like a two-dimensional ridiculous pirate
but he never really gets scenes with his
character to really flesh him out we are
naturally going to compare euron to past
villains in game of thrones and when
those villains weren't as ridiculous as
euron then on a comparison basis that
makes him even worse because arguably
joffrey and ramsey are just as crazy as
euron and if not way more and them on
their own never exuded the same type of
wacky energy that euron does sure
joffrey and ramsay have some chaotic and
scary moments but the reason why those
moments stand out so much and make them
menacing is because they're normally
more reserved and are utilizing the fact
that less is more
take ramsay as an example a character
who is bastard insane but in a lot of
his scenes he's normally more collected
and calculating making it to where that
puts the audience on edge because you
never know when he's going to snap and
do something hideous this made his
scenes with theon greyjoy so terrifying
because we never knew when ramsay was
suddenly going to get angry and hurt our
beloved character even more however with
euron he can never achieve that level of
intimidation because he's always overly
wacky and wild for the sake of just
being spontaneous and unpredictable then
there's also the issue of character
direction and the acting that comes
along with that and a fire cannot kill a
dragon it was revealed that the
intention for the character was to make
him more like a quote unquote rock star
dan weiss says we really haven't had
somebody in the show who has kind of a
rock star swagger
hearing that quote really just makes me
sick to my stomach and trust me it gets
worse they even went to the costume
designer to make yarn look like a rock
star by dressing them up in leather and
guideliner which as a comparison to the
books is straight up blasphemy from how
much cooler his design was like imagine
this design from the books with an actor
that isn't overacting and is instead
being silent and menacing again calling
back to less is more then jeremy
pardeswa one of the directors stated
that the script suggested that euron was
sexy and funny so pilo asbeck the actor
who plays euron played up that aspect of
the character in season 7 pilo insisted
of david and dan that his character
needed to be overly arrogant and
charming for the scene where he meets up
with jaime lannister because he had more
confidence to stand up for his rendition
of the character by that point in the
show upon his delivery of that scene
david and dan were actually really happy
that they allowed him to portray the
character in that way dany states to
have somebody traipse onto the stage
with the swagger and attitude that euron
had was a lot of fun because it lets air
into the room
so from all these behind the scenes
revelations it's painfully clear that
david and dan and the actor portraying
euron wanted to deliver a villain that
was drastically worse than the books and
on the subject of euron greyjoy being
changed into a frankenstein monster of
captain jack sparrow and the rockstar
let's look at his character in the books
and see how david and dan had great
material to work with but ultimately
ignored it
in the books euron is a cunning sharp
and manipulative intimidating figure
that constantly plays mind games with
any of his surrounding subjects he also
has a much cooler and badass design
where he wears black scale armor and he
even has an eye patch that supposedly
hides a black eye shining with malice so
right away that's way better than a hobo
and leather and guy liner there's also a
more magical aspect to his character in
which he drinks shade of the evening
that stains his lips and in general he's
way more obsessed with learning magic
that can aid him in bringing about an
apocalypse something that is entirely
dropped from the show along with his
meat crew called the silence they are
briefly mentioned in season 8 but barely
any emphasis was put on that so really
it seems like one of the only shared
characteristics these two characters
have is that they are both kind of
unpredictable and that's it but euron in
the show is unpredictable because it
feels like he just acts spontaneously
and is just trying to be overly crazy
meanwhile in the books euron is
unpredictable because we don't
necessarily know the exact scale of his
ambitions and the drastic lengths he is
willing to go to
in terms of fixing euron greyjoy it's
only realistic for the show to draw upon
the essence of book euron and how he
looks and acts because his story arc in
the book won't really work as a direct
one-to-one adaption in the show
especially since they are introducing
him in season 6. you can technically
introduce him much sooner and try to
execute his book narrative in a perfect
world but if we are working with the
show then i think making him look and
act like book euron will be the best
david den could have done but for some
idiotic reason they didn't utilize that
one integral aspect that makes a villain
stand out is that they need to make a
major impact so they can be feared
looking at euron the main impact he has
made before the final season to set him
up as a villain was killing balon
greyjoy failing to kill yar and theon
greyjoy and killing the sand snakes so
not the best rap sheet in comparison to
other villains in which they have done
truly horrible acts like joffrey killing
ned stark and torturing sansa tywin
orchestrating the red wedding and
constantly beating down his own family
and ramsay torturing and castrating a
character for multiple seasons these
characters make massive impacts and
thoroughly change the show from their
actions so right away you're probably
like yeah euron doesn't really make a
great impact in comparison to these
villains he just eats bail on off a
bridge a character who doesn't even show
up for seasons four and five and only
has one brief appearance in season three
so his epic introduction is him killing
a character that most people watching
the show don't really care about anymore
and has no more relevance in the books
baylon grijoli's death happens way
sooner around the point of season 2 or 3
for the show so by extending out his
show presence all the way to season six
because that's when he chose to
introduce euron it leaves very little
source material to work with for baelon
which thus leads to his character being
largely absent destroying his relevance
in the process then him killing the sand
snakes if anything was way more exciting
and cathartic for the audience because
of how much everyone hated them and it
felt like fan service euron doesn't make
a great impact currently and to me
there's a somewhat obvious fix to this
problem and that answer is in the books
i know this requires more build up in
introducing more characters but by
neutering the iron island's plot line
you simultaneously neuter euron because
in the books it's revealed that he's
killed three of his brothers making him
a major kinslayer however in the show
the impact of him being in kinslayer is
heavily reduced because of the fact that
the greyjoy house is virtually empty in
comparison to the books the people i was
cutting down were your own kin
place was getting crowded so how can
this character fanatically kill a bunch
of his brothers when he doesn't even
have any in the show besides balon this
also leads to a lot less conflict within
the iron islands given that he only has
a few relatives instead of a handful
more greyjoys for him to manipulate so
right away upon his introduction and
even throughout his time on the show
there is nothing that happens that
declares euron is an important villain
and even though he makes a bigger impact
in season 8 by killing one of daenerys
dragons and getting the final blow on
jaime those events still don't manage to
make him a better villain for rhaegal's
death it felt extremely contrived and
unrealistic which thus robs iran from
getting any form of antagonists that
clouds because right away the audience
will just be annoyed from the fact that
danny didn't know about the iron fleet
despite being reminded about them the
scene prior and now she didn't see a
massive fleet in the ocean and so on and
so on then for euron's other big moment
in which he fights jaime that moment is
also heavily contrived because of how
convenient it was for him to swim ashore
at the exact time and place in which
jaime was entering the right keep not to
mention that the fight between euron and
jaime was essentially pointless because
jaime just died to bricks instead of his
wound so even in a season where he's
fighting an act of war his character
still can't stand out as an impactful
villain
one reason why euron in the show may
seem like a boring character to follow
is that his primary goal and motivation
is to mainly have sex with cersei
ever since i was a little boy
i wanted to grow up and marry the most
beautiful woman in the world
[Laughter]
are you serious which for a man who has
traveled all over the world and has
experienced many fine women most likely
primarily having this motivation is
weird now it can also be about power but
if it was about that he would betray
cersei in a heartbeat and would take the
iron throne for himself now obviously no
one would want to see this buffoon on
the iron throne but it doesn't make
sense from his character's perspective
to be so loyal to someone he doesn't
really know and shouldn't care about
given that he killed his own brother in
an attempt to become king so he would
easily be classified as self-serving but
now he's trying to win the heart of
cersei unless if this is just all a play
one up jaime lannister since he seems
overly obsessed with the man in season
aids
so currently euron doesn't have a
realistic goal that isn't contrived for
the story and it seems like he primarily
operates to make cersei's side seem
stronger
in the books he has nothing to do with
cersei and he has his own entire agenda
going on so you can't look there for any
possible solutions for this show so
really the only thing to do is to
drastically change the character to fit
the new story which is essentially what
david and dan did which simultaneously
in their rendition of the character
ruined him what they should have done
instead was give euron more consistency
in terms of motivation and goals
instead of having a weird mix of
everything that amalgamates into a horny
pirate that wants to be loved who kind
of wants more power it doesn't
necessarily want to kill his relatives
and also wanting to at the same time to
me what seems like a more realistic
approach to the show version of euron is
a man obsessed with power and getting
revenge on his relatives for making him
look weak when they stole his fleet and
along the way of gaining his revenge he
also simultaneously gets closer to
cersei with the motivation of betraying
her and getting more power not fall in
love with her so obviously jaime sees
through that and eventually confronts
him much sooner and fights him before
season 8. this would also give a lot
more scenes within king's landing season
7 narrative since as it is it's
extremely sparse and there's really
nothing going on there since the high
sparrow is gone so why not have euron be
the villain threat for king's landing
that season and by the end jaime has to
confront him and rid this treasonous
parasite before he kills cersei and
cersei may be blinded by the fact that
she's so obsessed with trying to beat
daenerys and tyrion that she's getting
desperate for more allies this is really
the only course i can see realistically
happening with euron in the show that
isn't overly ridiculous and contrived
because in season 8 it just feels like
he's attacked on villain that doesn't
really have anything to offer and this
is also just me briefly spitballing
trying to come up with a better arc for
the character and i'm surprised that
dave and dan took years to come up with
what they did and how terrible it was
for one last quick aspect that should be
entirely removed from euron is his
humorful spirit
humor is a double-edged sword and is a
really hard personality trait to
incorporate for your villain because as
we know through the show it can
drastically undercut any serious and
menacing tone that the villain has going
for them and instead turns them into a
buffoon
and since steven and dan seem to be
pretty incompetent at writing original
riveting dramatic dialogue they take the
easy way out with having their
characters crack unfunny jokes more
frequently how can you be intimidated by
someone who is making [ __ ] jokes in
almost every scene he is in
even heard you have no [ __ ] that the
sort of thing you start to say once your
dick gets chopped off
along with my big [ __ ]
in fire cannot kill a dragon pilo even
stated that he was doing a comedy show
for the iron islands
which is absolutely absurd that he
thinks that he can give a stand-up
routine as one of the introductory
scenes of a villain if you really want
to make humor work with a villain use it
as a form of bait and switch disarm your
subject with humor and then come in with
your lethality kind of what happens with
ramsay acting more lighthearted to then
switch suddenly to be more scary to
catch leon off guard in a more
vulnerable state however with euron his
humorful side is just there for him to
be more charismatic and eccentric which
are characteristics that don't make a
great villain in this context these
characteristics can work for a villain
but not for euron greyjoy a character
that is supposed to be a menacing leader
that strikes fear amongst his ranks not
someone at king's mood who is trying to
make people laugh and love him and
attempt to win everyone's hearts so he
can become king who has a better [ __ ]
than euron the long
so from deleting his humorful side
changing his goals and overall arc to be
more realistic and consistent giving him
more of an impact so he can be feared
improving the acting and direction of
the character in his design and trying
to make him as close to his book
counterpart as possible is how i think
you can fix a seemingly unfixable
character thank you for watching and
have a great day
you